if you think sharing your location with your partner is for safety reasons,
or out of convenience,
then you're lying to yourself.
it's so funny to me when couples go on to explain that, that's the reason
what it's for.
don't lie to yourself.
you wanna know the real reason why you're sharing locations with your partner?
it's because you wanna stalk them.
come on you can't tell me that's not what it's for.
like if my partner says he's going somewhere,
then I'm instantly running to check.
making sure he gets there.
or if he's running late,
I'm instantly watching him drive down the road,
watching that little dot move around
We’re stalking our partners,
why are we lying about it?
if they don't respond right away,
you're instantly
like checking
where you at??
Not only that, whenever they turn off their location
you're instantly like hmmm,
“what's going on?”
“what's happening?”
you're never like oh,
“I hope they're safe”
instead you're spiraling because you don't have access to stalking them.
men and women both do this.
why aren't we fully transparent with each other?
we all do it.
we don’t do it for safety reasons.
we do it for convenience of stalking each other.
we do it out of love though,
we're love stalking.